Elon Musk was interviewed by Tucker
Carlson and the interview goes horribly
wrong you get the feeling that Tucker is
really desperate for Elon to like him
and much of what that includes is Tucker
doing the maniacal laughter when Elon
tells pretty mediocre jokes you funded
it at the beginning what happened yeah
well that would be ironic if it Faith
the most ironic outcome is most likely
it seems
um
that's good now Twitter by any objective
measure I hate to go back into toilet
humor but it's been flushed
significantly since Elon Musk took over
advertisers fleeing Twitter
engagement down this disastrous for you
feed that promotes mostly right-wing
nonsense Twitter blue where you can pay
to be verified and that went completely
backwards it's been very bad